the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let me start again
thanks for helping with Professor Rao
and working on the labs the last two
times I was saying the labs were really
for his class which is 90 minutes so
that we were kind of running out of time
just answering those questions you know
getting the system to say ok keep going
anyway he's going to develop those and I
think there'll be a good thing so
actually the second lab I was as I was
watching it I I was thinking of a math
question and may I report to you on that
math question so remember the lab was
completing a matrix you've got some
entries and you can put in any other
entries in the other positions and the
question was can you complete it to a
rank one matrix and so what was here's
my question what positions are ok and
what positions could you maybe not be
able to complete to a rank one matrix
examples are the best okay so so I'm
looking at this question here ok so
suppose I I'm looking for a rank one
matrix of the form X column y transpose
or UV transpose I guess we're those are
the letters we're used to UV transpose
and that means of course that a IJ each
a IJ
is UI times VJ right so we've got we're
able to choose we have M used let me ask
a question could I complete so let me
take m equal n equals 3 so 3 by 3 matrix
I'm gonna give you my sin minus 1 which
is 3 plus 3 minus 1 5 positions and
suppose I + 4 and give some non zeros in
which 5 positions
so Y is where is that number M plus n
minus 1 coming from well because I have
M use and I have envies for for Rank 1
matrix I goes from 1 to M J goes from 1
to N so I have M + n but obviously there
I could I could make I could require the
first you to be a 1 in other words when
I'm multiplying those there's one degree
of freedom that that is sort of repeated
here because if I'm just given you if
I'm just give just in the one anyway you
see it that that I can rescale the use
so that the first u is a 1 and and that
leaves me M + n - 1 so could I give you
these five numbers and could you
complete that to a rank one matrix so
those are non zeros why do I say none
zeros because if that number happened to
be a zero I'd have bad
if I prescribed that one and I
prescribed it to be zero then if every
column has to be a multiple of that
column these would all have to be zero
so I don't want that I want to be able
to prescribe five numbers and therefore
they better better not be zero okay
could you complete the job with that
choice of of five positions I think you
could because how would you decide on
that number well I'm at least one way to
look at it is what would that number be
there so this is that number would be
chosen there be one and only one choice
for that that would give rank one in
fact that little 2 by 2 determinant
would have to be 0 well write the all
the rows all the columns are supposed to
be multiples of one column all the rows
are supposed to be multiples of one row
all the two by twos are our rank 1
they're all and rank 1 for a 2 by 2
means determinant 0 so I would know what
that one had to be that number would
have to be a 1 2 times a 2 1 over a 1 1
that's because I have to get a every 2
by 2 determinant has to be 0 here if I
want Rank 1 I can't stand any two by
twos that are that are invertible
matrices so all the determinants have to
be 0
ok and of course then these 3 numbers
would allow me to fill in there those 3
numbers would allow me to fill that
those 3 numbers well I may fill that
it'd be easy easy so that I can see that
those are 5 positions that work
now give me five positions that won't
work so this is good this is check now I
want one that where I can't make it work
so let me give that number that number
okay well so I'm looking for something
that fails a set of positions that fails
and then I want to be able to test does
the set of positions work for any non
zeros or does it not work okay so I want
to get one another what am I looking for
here another a different one that works
okay so what else would work apart from
that let's see I suppose I take that one
now what about that position there I
must not choose that one right I must
not choose that one because that would
complete a two by two and if if I gave
the wrong numbers the determinant
wouldn't be zero and I would be failed
so I must not give that position maybe I
could give that position maybe I could
give this one how's that if I had those
five would I be able to complete it
looks good anyway it looks good let's
see how would I go about completing that
let's see I could I would know what that
number had to be from this two by two
from this two by two I would know that
number from this sir where now this and
this and this now that's not any good
what do I do now to get how would I get
this number
oh okay I guess I have to use so to get
this would complete that or this two by
two oh yeah okay no problem
that would never complete that one right
but this one I don't think I can get
immediately but I can get it once I know
these then obviously I can get that I
can get that right so I have to
it's a sort of nice combinatorial
problem which which five positions will
work which five which five will not work
how do I tell so or of course that's for
3x3 yeah so let me I had a like a bigger
example let me let me move up to 4x4 so
so now here's here comes the idea that I
learned last night from a math professor
who does combinatoric s-- so these
people who do combinatorics they've know
stuff that the rest of us don't
okay so here's the his his view is to
take have these would be rows one two
three I may I may add another row let me
do a 4x4 and these would be columns one
two three four
okay now I'm looking for seven so so if
I prescribed an entry I'll put in a edge
between them so let me let me hype hype
this one up to 4x4 yeah yeah it's a good
one actually I'll just draw this picture
so suppose I prescribed the one one oh
yeah and over here I'll show you what
I've done so that I'm putting in the one
one position I'm looking for seven right
four plus four minus one seven numbers
okay
then I'll put in this is Row two column
one row two column one that would be
there then I'll put in a two to four so
that would be Row two column four then
I'll put in a three to four so that
would be Row 3 column 4 and finally I'll
put in let's see so how many have I done
one two three four and I've got to get
up to seven prescribe seven
well let me I mean I'll put a foot
Mauryan okay so so on row four I gave
two three and four and did I put in this
one yes I did okay well so I've now
prescribed seven seven numbers could I
complete the matrix to rank one matrix
how you see the math question if I'm
given seven positions there I can this
is another way to look at the same
picture this is I put in an edge for
every X so if I have seven X's I've got
seven edges and and this is called a
bipartite graph so it's a graph I've got
four nodes here four nodes here so I
have eight nodes
it's a bipartite graph because the the
nodes I have one part of nodes over
there one part of nodes here bipartite
means two parts so the rows give me one
part of the edges the columns give me
the other part of the edges and all the
connections go between the parts I'm not
I don't have any lines from from a row
to a row because all the whole code is
that this tells me what where those
seven positions are okay now I'm just
going to ask you can I complete the
graph can I complete the matrix can I
complete rank one matrix there okay what
do you think so the and the real
question is what's the rule what what
what's the how can I see when I can't
complete the matrix something gets in
the way here what God in the way was
this 2x2
and actually I asked the question on
email is it can I always complete it
yeah
so let me that would be the question I
could ask you can I always complete the
graph you complete the matrix to have
Rank 1 when there when I don't run into
this is that all I have to avoid a
two-by-two where I've given three where
I'm given all four entries so yeah here
this I I was able to complete yeah so so
sorry duh let's do one if I if I'm given
those entries and maybe some others I
guess seven altogether that's a failure
right I if I can't prescribe any non
zeros in those seven positions because
if I prescribe any non zeros I probably
won't have a zero determinant here I
won't have rank one that that column
will be will not be a multiple of that
column whatever I do here I've screwed
up already so that's a fail okay right
and how do I let me take that picture
and and turn it into this picture
so rows columns so if I take these seven
that's Row 1 Row 1 2 3 4 so Row 1 goes
to 1 and 2 Row 2 goes to 1 and 2 Row 3
goes to 4 and Row 4 goes to 3 and 4
that's a failure and how do I know it's
a failure I want to now come up with the
answer come up with the answer so if I
give any 7 positions or any M plus n
minus 1 positions like that I can create
a graph like that just following the
rule that you saw those
seven positions gave me seven edges in
my graph and it's a bipartite graph
because every edge goes from this part
over to this part and that's a failure
and the reason it's a failure is the
reason it's a failure is that I have
here a cycle if I go across down across
down I come back where I started that
would be a cycle equals failure big
everybody sees I can't give these four
numbers generally I would have to manin
you three I don't have any freedom left
where that fourth one and the way to see
that in this picture is that that's that
there's a cycle so here's the
combinatoric thing that that Professor
Posner COFF told me about last night you
can complete to a rank one matrix if and
only if no cycles so that was a that was
a that's a just answered my question
perfectly
this one is one where I can complete and
it's got a cycle cycle meaning you come
back to where you started but so I I
thought maybe so my question to him
which was was can you always complete it
if there are no two by twos in the way
and his answers told me that maybe the
two by twos could be okay but there
could be a bigger cycle a longer cycle
that would screw you up so let me close
with with an example of that sort
so this is going to be fail again
but but no 2x2 is responsible in other
words it's gonna fail I won't be able to
complete this matrix even so there
aren't any completed two by twos a 2 by
a 2 by 2 I knew immediately was failure
so let me see if I can do that okay okay
so here's a failure Row 1 2 this is rows
1 2 3 4 and this is columns 1 2 3 4 and
I think I'm gonna have a 1 given there
and yeah I sort of started this before
and 2 goes to 1 & 4 & 3 goes to 4 and 4
goes to that safe bet okay now I've only
put in 2 4 5 and I'm allowed 7 but I
think I'm already in trouble here so let
me let me draw this picture for this so
this is rows 1 2 3 4 and this is columns
1 2 3 4 and now what if I I've
prescribed that one I know that goes
from oh my forgotten the right way to do
the picture my by.bite my bipartite
graph wasn't what it should have been so
that 1 2 3 4 okay now I'm going to do
the the bipartite graph picture that
goes with this picture so 1 2 1 1 2 2 1
2 2 4 what I'm gonna do
let me just say what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna create a cycle over here of length
6 a cycle of length 4 is what I got from
a 2 by 2 by 2 by 2 that took me 1 one
way back another back another back
another I completed a cycle I came back
to where I started
with just four edges now I want a
complete one complete a cycle with 6
edges so let me let me draw it in the
picture here then now I'm going to put
an edge from four back to one so so 1 1
2 1 1 2 4 2 2 1 2 2 4 if I got any yeah
I think 1 2
goddamn I didn't want a short cycle I
want a bigger longer cycle let me if you
let me get the darn thing so 2 2 4 is
not what I want so I here start a cycle
ok go somewhere go back go somewhere go
back go somewhere go back now there I
got it length 6 length 6 so now let me
put the X's in where they belong now so
one is connected to one and four that's
right 2 is connected to 2 and 4 3 is not
connected to anybody let's let's put
that one in and 4 is connected to 1 and
2 4 is connected to 1 & 2
ok I believe this I believe that picture
goes with that picture now my claim is
that there are no there there's no 2 by
2 in here that shows me immediately
failure but I will fail I can't live
with that
with those that looks like 8
sorry I've got I only want seven so I
just shall I just take sorry three four
and that shouldn't be there right okay
thanks
all right you see I'm not a combinatoric
person but it's so beautiful to have the
inspiration to convert that picture to
this picture and then realize that a
problem in this picture is a cycle in
this picture that's the whole message
that's the whole message that when I'm
looking here a cycle means that I'm I've
built in a requirement which random
non-zeros won't satisfy so you see that
anyway you see the cycle 1 1 2 3 4 5 6
yeah yeah so there's a cycle there so
somehow those 6 X's whichever they are I
guess not all but 2 3 visor 3 so I could
take I could take away this part of the
graph and just have 3 and 3 and there
would be 6 numbers in there and that's
two men yeah ok ok I'm gonna stop there
exactly halfway through the class but
well I'm gonna stop there with a
question which I don't know I don't know
if I dare send another question that
professor poster coffee who answered
this one perfectly but the question
would be when could you complete a rank
2 matrix what what positions could you
fill in and be able to reach rank 2 that
would be trouble right I don't know
where we would go with that but anyway
but that's a net for us for 18 or 65
that's the natural question when could I
we rank 1 is super special for us and
rank 2 or rank
would be the general case yeah so so
they're good math questions now topic 2
convolution so the first lab in the
course just happened to have a
convolution and use that word and so on
but we did not but we didn't connect
that with the lectures so now I'd like
to talk about convolutions which are
extremely important and they are
important in machine learning because
they give you a set of weights
connecting they're an efficient way to -
let me show you let me show you ok
so a convolution matrix and this will be
a cyclic convolution mate ok and the
word the shorthand for cyclic
convolution matrix is circulant so what
is a circulant we'll call it C a
circulant has some mminton diagonals
that's what convolution means matrix was
convolution means constant
down each diagonal
and cyclic means complete circle around
again the diagonals diagonals circle
around so let us show you what I mean so
four by four let's say so it has some
entry to there's one diagonal here is
another diagonal so now I have constant
diagonals but if it's going to be a
circulant matrix and this is the best
family of matrices in the world the
algebra is just terrific for these
matrices and that's why they're the
heart of signal processing so so this is
a constant diagonal matrix but it's not
yet a circulant that diagonal circles
around to put to be completed every
diagonal has four entries here so let me
take another one say one one then that
would circle around a11 and this guy
could be 0 there's a circulant matrix
you understand then what the entry you
only need four numbers say the first
column if you if you prescribed the
first column of a circulant matrix then
you've told MATLAB for example all all
it needs to know if you tell it one
column it can get all the other columns
just by cyclic shift there's the first
column 2 0 1 5 the second column is 2 0
1 5 shifted down by 1 the next column is
again shifted down by 1 2 0 1 5 and the
last column is 2 0 1 5 so they're all
the same columns after a cyclic shift
so the key matrix in this is really a
cyclic shift matrix say zero one zero
zero zero zero so it just says one
nonzero diagonal and then it's cyclic
you see that in fact this matrix C is I
can produce this matrix C from P and P
squared yeah can I just put in what
would P squared beats I'll write it here
without keeping that while keeping our
eye on P so if I square that matrix what
matrix would I get so it's this is a
shift by one if I shift by one again
that's multiplying again by P so that
would give me P squared
what what's in the what's in the okay so
what happens now it's shift by two I
guess so so this will be 0 0 1 0 this
will be 0 0 0 1 then I'm its cyclic
still so I'm put in the ones there and
then just fill in the zero ok so P
squared shift by 2 you start out with
this one yep is that right yes yes ok ok
yeah let's just let's just make it
multiply a vector X naught X 1 X 2 X 3
what it what it does is it puts it well
I've started the numbering with 2 here X
2 X 3
x0 and x1 so it shifted it by two and
and cyclically so the x2 x3 that got
shifted off the bottom come back to the
top okay what I want to show the first
property is of circulant so so suppose I
have matrices see in the circular so
fact 1 C times D is also a circular so
if I multiply circulant matrices I get
more circulant matrices and the identity
is a circulant matrix I have a little
group of matrices the best little group
of matrices there is I can multiply two
guys in the group and I get another one
in the group well why is CD also a
circulant let's see can we see why that
fact is true I guess here's my way to
look at it a circulant matrix let me put
it put it here a circulant matrix every
circulant matrix is C naught times the
identity circulant plus C 1 times the
single shift plus C 2 times the double
shift plus C 3 times the triple shift
that that's what it takes to put C
naught C 1 C 2 and C 3 on those
diagonals C naught is obviously on the
main diagonal C 1 P remember what P is
that puts C one on the next diagonal
then C 2 P squared when i square this
I've shifted by one more so it will put
C 2 on that dying
and finally c3 would go in those
positions so every circulant matrix is a
polynomial in P in a single shift this
is any combination of shifts this is a
single shift that's a double shift
that's a triple shift that's a zero
shift and if I take combinations i get i
get a circulant matrix so so now I can
see why CD is also a circulant because
this is a polynomial in P and this is a
polynomial in P and when I multiply
those together I get a polynomial in P
but usually if I multiply a third degree
polynomial by us another third degree
polynomial so say I'm looking at four by
four circulant matrices so this would be
a polynomial P NP a third degree three
and this would be a polynomial degree 3
so that would give me a polynomial of
degree 6 but I don't want that that's
somehow I have to define multiplication
so that I want this to be degree these
are all supposed to be 4 by 4 matrices
just like that one
that's twice the identity plus 5 P plus
1 P squared plus 0 P cubed and suppose I
square that then again I'm going to get
a circulant matrix and I don't want it
to go up to degree 7 I want you know I
just want four terms in my polynomial
I just want the main diagonal in the
next three diagonals and then cyclic
cycling around completes the matrix so
why what's how do I get ha ha
how to get degree threes that's the
question then can you just tell me the
answer so I'm multiplying yeah let's
just do an example so I've seen not C 1
p c 2 P squared C 3 P cubed times D
naught plus P 1 P plus D 2 P squared and
D 3 P cubed so that's P is this P is 4
by 4 circular shift okay and I'm writing
the 4 by 4 matrix that way this is this
should be the identity of course okay so
when I multiply those guys why do I not
get degree 6 why am i why is that
product like P cubed times P cubed C 3 P
cubed NT 3 P cube that gives me C 3 D 3
P to the 6th power
so what's up what do I do yeah yes
that's the key that's the periodic part
P to the 4 equal the identity thank ya
so the P to the sixth term is really a P
squared term the P to the fifth term is
really a P term the P to the fourth term
is really a P to the 0 term so yeah so
I'm I'm just doing I'm doing what I'm
doing cyclic convolution actually let me
just say when I'm multiplying yeah
so I'm now I'm telling you what I can
first tell you what convolution is and
then what cyclic convolution is and this
is real listen up to this because it's
it's a good thing to know
yeah so first of all convolution
so we suppose I want to take the
convolution of three one two that's
often the symbol for convolution with
four six one okay so how do i how what
does that mean I've got a vector so
what's high for me what's hiding there
is is polynomials three plus X plus two
x squared times four plus 6x plus one x
squared and I just multiply them out and
I get five so I get 3 times 4 gives me a
12 3 times 6x is 18x but I've also got
4x from here so I've got 22 X so I just
do that multiplication of polynomials
and what I'm doing is convolution with
the vectors and here's the way you wrote
it in in first grade
okay so here's first grade okay
212 8 this is you haven't learned to
carry yeah so 12 goes in there as 12
then 1 is 4 6 1 & 3 is 12 18 3 and then
you add up so you have 2 13 17 22 and 12
let me just so so that that's the answer
there that their convolution I guess I
have to take it from yeah 12 3 times 4
gave 12 now 3 times 6 plus 1 times 4
that's the 22
oh yeah we already started here but now
what's after that 17 why did I say seven
teeth oh eight plus six plus three
Thanks
seventeen and then twelve plus one
thirteen and then - that's non-cyclic so
that's convolution oh if I if I want it
to be non-cyclic I don't put a circle in
so that's a symbol for ordinary
convolution if you do the MATLAB command
Co NV for convolution if you gave it
those vectors it would give you five a
vector with five components as a result
but if you now let me make it six like
okay so what's going to happen now when
I make it cyclic so this represents 12
22 P 17 P squared 13 P cubed and what
happens what's 13 P cubed if I'm doing
if n is 3 and I'm doing 3 by 3 matrices
then 13 P cube is the same as 13 right P
cube is I so the 13 will go back there
and the 2 will be P 4th and it'll go
back as P so so the now with convolution
cyclic convolution gives 12 and 13 25 22
and 224 and the 17 okay so I've get I'm
getting back a vector of length 3 I just
as I want to do if I have a 3 by 3
matrix convolution cyclic circulant
matrix were those three diagonals and
these three diagonals and I want the
answer to be a three by three matrix
were these diagonals so again matrix
multiplication
circulant matrices corresponds exactly
to multiplying polynomials cyclically
and that's cyclic convolution and then
there's just one little trick to see if
you've got the numbers right I believe
that it should be true that if 3 plus 1
plus 2 is 6 4 plus 6 plus 1 is 11 and I
believe that those should add to add to
what what do I hope that they add 266
I'm a little nervous about doing it but
I think we can yeah so 49 50 966 check
yeah so the the digits the sum of the
digits of one factor multiplies the sum
of the digits of the other factor to
give the sum of the digits in the
convolution and that would be true
whether we doing cyclic which is
bringing the 13 and the tube back in or
not cyclic where where we have five
numbers yeah so that's that's actually a
check that little that I don't know if
you've ever thought about that in second
grade
multiplying these numbers multiplying
that number by that number and getting
some answer which probably half the
class did not get right then 5th grade
they've they're kind of getting it but
if they knew a check so they could have
just added these numbers to get 11 added
these numbers to get 6 multiplied those
to get 66 and check that that those
added 266 I'd never had occurred to me
I admit and second grade neither but
it's a good thing now you know now you
can pass second grade okay so so this is
the picture for cyclic convolution and I
just have a few minutes left to tell you
about the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of these matrices so what can you tell
me about the eigenvalues and i say the
eigenvectors i have a matrix p happens
to be a permutation matrix but it's a
matrix then I take this polynomial in
the matrix what can you tell me about
the eigenvectors of this matrix C so I
have write my C looks like looks like
that and I'm asking you for the
eigenvectors of that and I'm saying that
that is a is a sum of is a polynomial
sum of powers of P like so in fact
numbers here just come off the diagonals
so what about the eigenvectors well that
is an eigenvector that's true the vector
of all ones will be an eigenvector with
what eigenvalue actually yeah yeah so I
what I wanted to want you to see is the
eigenvectors of C are the same as the
eigenvectors of P if I have an
eigenvector of p that's also an
eigenvector of p squared and P cubed and
a combination so eigenvectors of P are
eigenvectors of seats
so then the question is what are the
eigenvectors of P you see what I mean
that it doesn't it didn't really matter
if I'm looking for eigenvectors what
those numbers were the point is that
those numbers were constant on diagonals
and that they therefore they I have it's
built out of one matrix P built out of
one matrix P so if all I have to do is
the eigenvectors of P yep so that's the
final step here what are the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of p so
eigenvectors eigenvalues for p equal 1 1
1 and 1 say and otherwise 0 so somebody
mentioned that the vector of 1 1 1 1
that that is an eigenvector because if I
do that multiplication it shifts this
vector down and cyclically around but
that just brings back the same vector so
lambda is 1 and that's an eigenvector
with eigenvalue 1 but this is a 4 by 4
matrix
oh now you're guessing 1 minus 1 1 minus
1 interesting well right tell me an
eigenvector 4 minus 1 if you want to bro
just alternating signs there so let me
let me do that multiplication times 1
minus 1 1 minus 1 of course I don't have
to do this multiplication I'm just going
to shift this so I'm going to shift that
down
1 minus 1 1 and cyclically around and
now what's the eigenvalue it is an
eigenvector and what's the eigenvalue
that makes what multiple of that vector
gives that gives that vector minus 1 so
that was a good idea but the rest of
what you said was was a bad idea because
we've got to look the next eigen vectors
are got to be somewhere else we've just
got one eigenvalue there on 1 there and
we haven't got the other two so what are
the other two eigenvalues of this
permutation matrix one that's right
we're in a circulant world draw a circle
so the eigenvectors are the four roots
of one complex so one and minus one
you've got these are the lambdas but the
other ones are i and- i yeah yep why
don't I leave until since time's up let
me leave until Friday the eigen values
and eigen vectors for in general for
arbitrary size but that's a picture of
the eigen we're close to the eigen
vectors and eigen values of every all
circulant have the same eigen vectors
all circulant have that eigenvector also
four by four all circulant have that
eigenvector four by four and we'll find
the other two okay so I'll see you
Friday for those and the convolution
rule which is the most important rule in
signal processing okay thanks